Based on the data below,
which student's score improved
the most between the
midterm and final exams?
And so they give us
this data in terms
of a bar graph for each student.
We actually have two bars
that show the midterm in blue
and then the final exam in red.
And they tell us that here--
midterm in blue and final exam.
And sometimes this is called
a two-column bar graph
because for each student here
you have two columns of data.
So if you were to actually
look at the data itself,
you have the midterm
data and then
you have the final exam data.
Now, they're asking us which
student's score improved
the most between the
midterms and the final exams?
So if we look at
Jasmine right over here,
might as well start
with her since she's
the most to the left.
It looks like she definitely
did improve from the midterm
to the final.
It looks like in the
midterm, if I had to guess,
this looks like about
a, I don't know,
it looks like she got
maybe about a 72 or 73
on the midterm.
I'm just guessing because I
don't know the exact number.
And then it looks like on the
final she got, I don't know,
that looks like maybe a
77 or 78 approximately.
So she improved a little
bit, about five points
from the midterm to the final.
The way that they've
given us this information,
we don't know the exact
numbers because it's not
super precise in terms
of marking off the bars,
but hopefully it'll
become obvious
when we look through
everyone's scores.
Let's look at Jeff.
So Jeff actually did worse from
the midterm to the final exam.
He got looks like over
an 85 on the midterm
and then on the final he
got about 84 or an 85.
So he actually went down.
So it's definitely not Jeff.
He definitely did
not improve the most.
He actually went down.
Next, if you think
about Nevin, it
looks like Nevin actually
improved about the same amount
as Jasmine.
On both scores, I don't know if
Nevin is a boy or girl's name,
this person on both tests, this
person did better than Jasmine,
but it looks like the actual
improvement is about the same.
Looks like they went from
about 83 to, I don't know,
about an 88.
I'm just estimating
it, just trying
to look at this axis
right over there
and estimating what
those scores are.
So Nevin and Jasmine right now,
based on the three we've seen,
are tied for the lead.
Now let's look at Alejandra.
Now Alejandra-- OK,
so this jumps out.
She definitely improved
dramatically from the midterm
to the final exam.
It looks like on the midterm
she maybe got an 81 or an 82.
So maybe this was an 82
she got on the midterm,
and then on the final, it
looks she got about a 95
on the final.
So there's dramatic improvement.
So right now Alejandra
is the leading contender
for most improved from
the midterm to the final.
And then finally
Marta, right over here,
it looks like she actually
got worse from the midterm
to the final.
She scored in the mid-90s
in the midterm and then low
90s in the final.
So she's definitely
not the most improved.
So the winner here is Alejandra.
Alejandra is the most
improved between the midterm
and the final exam.